la suite de notre feuilleton maintenant
je vous rappelle que nous vivons une
campagne de recrutement très
particulière puisqu'il s'agit
d'embaucher mille cinq cents saisonniers
pour le parc astérix le parquet ouvrira
samedi prochain avec un spectacle placé
sous le signe des vikings jongleurs
cascadeur et bonimenteurs vont évoluer à
bord d'un drakkar est pour le moment
vous allez le voir il enchaîne les
entraînements constitution
entre deux paires de baffes derniers
réglages pour le nouveau spectacle le
département des vikings maintenant
l'idée qu'on en oublie on est à
contretemps à l'énergie la banane et je
pensais aux cours ils ont donné derrière
nous sommes dans un hangar discret loin
du parc astérix à la mise en scène des
artistes de rues les bus ratine y est
sur scène des gens qui viennent d'une
école de cirque
il y en a d'autres qui viennent
avec d'autres expériences il ya on a
fait des castings et on a réuni tout ça
avec des gens qui travaillent déjà sur
le parti
en coulisses aussi on s'active à l'étagé
un atelier de couture a été montée à la
hâte pour fournir les costumes en temps
record
notre beau
pour carrie c'est la première répétition
à quelques heures de l'ouverture du parc
quand ils arrivent au fiancé passer
d'une chorégraphie de madonna à celle
d'un village gaulois bien sûr ça
nécessite quelques ajustements mais pas
prêt comme on le voudrait revoilà donc
c'est ça ce niveau là que c'est une
déception mais une finale je me contente
de faire la gauloise et nîmes
mais je m'attendais à un film dansé et
chanté en fait je m'attendais pas à
autant jouer la comédie
pas de répit pour les jeunes cascadeur à
peine formés aux scènes de cape et
d'épée les voilà entraînés maintenant en
gangster dans le spectacle main basse
sur la joue gros quand vous êtes prêt à
l'est
la dangerosité
tourné dans l'espace trop tôt à ce
moment là le talon vient accrocher le
bord supérieur de la fenêtre et on vient
se planter les canines dans le béton qui
est juste en dessous peu étaient déjà là
l'an dernier on les surnomme les
irréductibles
cette violente mais on a des protections
donc voilà on gère le risque
le maire pierre
les joueurs
et le le drakkar est baptisé il
s'apprête à rejoindre le village gaulois
en théorie il est assez solide pour
pouvoir durer quelques saisons au parc
astérix
là ça n'est pas vraiment prévu dans le
spectacle il lui reste donc un pont mais
qu'il peut résister mais aussi aux
envahisseurs
cette fois c'est la bonne pour toute
l'équipe si les préparatifs sont tout
juste terminé la saison elle ne fait que
commencer
engagez-vous par toutatis un feuilleton
signé stéphane despinoy francis forget
alain dumas arnaud b revel et nicolas
berthelot foule